welcome to this video yet another video
covering one of my over the bar
tournament games played in the european
club cab in bilbao spain this is the
fourth game on their plate and the game
we're faced them strongest opponent my
opponent in this game is the italian
number two player daniela vaca to roll
he's a grandmaster rated slightly below
2600 you know yeah of course he's the
number two behind fabiano caruana so I'm
not nothing to be happier shamed of yeah
we actually played the italian team and
if you remember that i'm playing on
board 5 and i got a 2600 player yeah
this pretty much means that this was a
super strong team and it was it was
really great to play against the steam
because they played with bought one car
wanna bore two nakamura bought three
vashi lagrave and bought for Prezi name
so four players above 2700 and with
kawana even the world number two so I'm
fantastic to play against such a team
yeah I played against vaca to Rome and
it was a slight surprise that i played
him because we had some small hiccup in
the in the organization and my
preparation time was a bit limited not a
problem really because it wasn't so
clear what he's playing anyway he played
the king's indian in his head the kings
in his repertoire and also an enzo
Rogozin queen's gambit some lights yeah
at the end I
looked at some stuff but it was tough to
really am completely prepare I went
deform the reason is that in case of him
playing with with e6e when g6 Kings
inion but in case of e-cigs I wanted to
allow the NIMS oh and yeah I didn't want
to get to the those Queens gambit
structured with Bishop before I don't
know them so well and this is what I
could have got never started Knight f3
so this was my reason why I'm when we're
started with with deform okay he played
g6 so we got a king's indian and again i
played my plate the classical which was
part of my preparation he five castles
yeah locked out of my preparation for
the game but a recent thing that i
looked at and he went now after some
thought which was quite curious in my
prep i had seen that he always went
nights his six year after which i could
have gotten in my prep are not showing
what exactly i had prepared in the
classical because something that I want
to use in her later games but it was
quite funny he always had played knight
c6 in prior games and here he took
minutes and then went with Queenie eight
surprisingly yeah this is a rare move um
and to be honest I think it's a bad news
however wide needs to know how to how to
fight it I played the best reply because
I had seen this recently in a game takes
and B form i recently had seen a game
cronic with white against a morir a key
from the tromsø olympiad and in this
game before Queenie 7b five was played
and crowned egg one quickly against a
moody a key America is a strong well
nossor is rated 2500
50 if I'm not mistaken is the number one
playoff Katara I hope I'm not confusing
things here and I think to be honest to
be perfectly frank here to play that
line with black against Gramlich is
basically the same as not not showing up
for the game you will lose without a
fight pretty weird that he played that
yeah I can briefly just briefly show you
what happened I mean the big point is
that white gains lots of space and will
get even further tempe on the Queen in
the game here are meraki I'll more yucky
played a 6 a-4 takes takes rook 28
Quincy to Bishop e3 yeah and we already
see that white has a huge advantage he's
got so much more space he can he will
get pressure against his seven it is a
real disaster you know even upon is just
lost for for nothing and he resigned a
couple of months later white is already
winning so I knew that the some magnets
good Becky more I knew that this this
before line is the way to go but i
didn't knew didn't know anything more i
am queen e 75 now my opponent didn't
play a 6 he played the move look to d8
they are not this but look the aid yeah
and here i think i missed a chance and I
played Quincy to him which is not yeah
like terribly bad but it's not the best
move in the position and my mistake was
I I thought about 95 here it's not that
I didn't look at the move but I failed
to appreciate one key point 95 is strong
here really strong
and the reason is black is pretty much
for us to take one point out saying he
needs to take this and of course I saw
that and then immediately thought wow
this is nice yeah i'm going to get an A
for Bishop e3 yeah those kind of moves
and then I saw and saw that he can play
a six and then I stopped and thought
well again this isn't that great right
what now if I am yeah if I let's say I
play a form he will take and all of a
sudden he's getting some sort of counter
play the Queen and rook here this is not
a good this is not a good spot to be in
so I didn't like that so much honor the
son and what I fail to recognize is that
after a six White has a much stronger
move Wyatt can play the move Queen a
form which looks weird in a way because
yeah what does the quit too honey for it
looks more natural to put the pond there
but this is very strong it is really
strong Queen a form is preparing the
very direct bishop a three just like
that black cannot take b5 and how
exactly are you going to develop now
yeah my next move the moose moose will
be Bishop a three or possibly sometimes
Bishop g5 and Roxy one why does far
better develop anyway and you don't have
a news this is a really really bad
position for black I didn't think about
Queen fo at all I mean I don't know I
was just thinking yeah a six and when
the pawn on d5 is going then he will be
able to develop but that's not happening
Queen a4 is just a very strong boo I'm
not sure why I didn't see it I mean
and I was really only concerned about a
six year maybe c6 but this is a game
that I found with c6 Bishop c4 takes
takes be should be six Bishop g5 taken
and Bishop e7 splat and wide wins yeah
at least a pawn and a good position this
is a game chariots dawn of trata from
1997 yeah nothing that i knew i was
aware of but it's kind of clear that
this is good for y to the c6 i was only
worried about a six but i failed to
really appreciate the Queen a4 thing
yeah 95 was a very good chance to get a
big advantage yeah I didn't do that I
didn't see that all and all I played
Quincy to okay 22 he went c6 and a for
this was what was I what I was was
saying before I saw okay Bishop a three
year so it moves that will come with the
tempo and I have a huge space advantage
on the queenside however what always
needs to be be kept in mind
strategically speaking this whole setup
for white also involves risk and the
risk is from a strategic point of view
that d 4 is a weak spot this is
especially emphasized by the fact that
black is able to play Bishop g4 here
wants to take off this night on a 3
which is a defender of the d4 square and
if he is giving is given enough time
then black will have a nice position
just imagine if we somehow would
transfer the night from here from be 82
e 6 yeah it takes over here here here
then it comes to deform and this is a
monster night so hmm I need to be
cautious however
i had i think evaluated this correctly
bishop in three Queen back and a five my
valuation wats that my initiative this
pawn roller is so quick that it does not
really it will not count to the
situation where he can use my default
weakness one important point is that
black really is never in any position to
take on on b5 him here you took on f3
which is a good movement if we just
consider this this is really never an
idea for to reason to photo reasons
sometimes it's just this move with those
kind of Nigel's but also from from a
purely positional point of view in this
move is also very helpful for me I get
this Bishop activated here probably not
be five is stronger but the general
point that he took on a 3 which i think
is the right right decision he could
have thought I played a six this is also
interesting then I take on c6 night
takes yeah note that pawn takes can also
be answered by this and all of a sudden
b6 is a huge weakness so Knight takes
and then something like 95 and this
leads to an interesting position I have
the super strong knight on d5 which she
needs to get rid of Queen B 5 work T 1
this was an alternative I mean black is
not not in a terrible in a terrible
shape here interesting an interesting
position may be equal
it didn't happen I think I think his
decision was right he took on a three
takes and the bishop f8 this was his
concept he wants to trade off those
bishops a bad bishop on one g72 after
this trade queen of eight also was
possible after this trade emphasized the
dark squared weaknesses okay luke t 1
what I'm what I'm basically a yeah
hoping for almost playing on is the
better development I have all pieces in
play and he still has the night on be
eight it's not so easy to develop this
piece what he did is he did exactly that
he took on d1 it now went night bd7
trying to develop the piece and this was
not such an easy move to make because of
what happens in the game and this was
exactly what I was anticipating that
night bd7 is not a move that she can
play so easily and I now played the move
a six and this is mandatory I must do
that and this was also it was also
planned if I don't do that it might
happen that he gets to this position
with the night on c5 the night on his
six and the knight on d4 with two nights
against a very very stupid looking
bishop on f3 yeah so 97 and a six that's
mandatory absolutely okay he took them
on a 6-1 else and I took c6 aha so I'm
getting a pawn to c6 which is at the
moment not very well supported 95 n c7
this was clear it was a matter of a
correct calculation Black now has only
precisely one line but exactly what he
played he had seen this before and when
he played
9b d7 and I had seen it as well of
course rook c8 95 yeah this keeps the
porn on c7 and text the night now it's
important black cannot take here as this
is leading to a very unlucky situation
now what he needs to do is he needs to
play Queen c6 this is the only move but
the month that that keeps the position
in balance yeah I'm very interesting
position now what can I do I was
thinking for a while here and then went
Quincy three I am I didn't evaluate this
quite correctly to be honest I thought
that I would still play for an advantage
but it's probably not true yeah well
Quincy three I still think that this is
the right move front by the way he took
one d5 and here an interesting position
rises originally I was thinking that I
can take also with the pawns yeah like
Ed yeah something like that e takes d5
Queen d6 import yeah not this one after
d6 white white has a huge huge advantage
this is especially true for see text e6
and the note that the bishop is also
coming into the play he five is hanging
white is winning I immediately he has to
go here yep blocking the pawn and only
then taking it back and note that like
he has a very solid block head down the
dark squares with night on c5 yeah I can
I can do something like this like here
this is f 6 h-4 group c 70 this this
this kind of position but this is
nothing nothing clear I mean nothing
that
that black must be totally scared about
his upon up and he's got a solid located
that's not easy to break so ultimately I
thought that taking with a pawn is
probably even a bit risky and then I
took only five with the Queen I can do
that because I have the intermediate
have this threat on HHM we need to look
on CL he has no other moves than Queen
takes there is nothing else something
like that for example I'm sorry I'm
winning the rook the NTS no other other
move odds with the night of him that's a
close here yeah I go here so he must
play Queen takes
yeah Queen takes nap and now I'm there
is no no big choice Queen takes and t 1
96 and originally I thought that I still
could do something in this position like
playing for an advantage in some way but
when I was looking at it a little bit a
little bit deeper and deeper it took me
not so long but once it was on the board
maybe I recognized oh wait this wasn't
such a great calculation he's just
threatening Luke 28 and rook the eight
wins the Queen I have no square yeah and
ce4 hangs so hmm not so easy all of a
sudden yeah okay it's not like I mean in
in big trouble but I really don't have
much yeah probably much else than 'if
I've the computer also points out the
rook a one but i didn't i didn't really
consider that very much yeah yeah whoo
k1 intending to go to a five him this is
this line who create queen 85 it's also
possible um yeah I went if I if this is
also active yeah he took on c4 which is
right I gave the check King here and
Queenie seven this was my idea when I
was was going for that activating the
Queen not going for passive defense I
have Queen f6 play on the dark squares
after I have secured my back rank I
might even have rocket e7 note that legs
extra porn at the moment is this double
pawn the a6 and a7 thorne so it's not
like he's got a comfortable simple extra
porn I have come to play also queen s
have legs
example he went to see five-term yeah
there were alternatives you can also go
to f4 by the way then I take here takes
here take care and after this we will
get the drawn position really very
simple or a simple draw um yeah Quincy
five is maybe them maybe the more
testing move what he played I gave the
check King g8 and now I went age for
right now here we both didn't have so
much time on the clock there were
alternatives Bishop g4 also looked
looked interesting after that he can go
Quincy to which irritated me but it's
not a big deal in fact I have a good
move with age three and this is what I
did not really consider that much the
idea is that now roop this happened
comes into the into the equation Roxy
for for example now and yeah the point
is i still cannot take only success is
this hangs this Hank um however I can
fall the draw now like this then and we
we have a draw yeah so Bishop g4 was was
a good alternative but okay I went h4
time was was limited both it's not it's
not a huge difference it seems that with
enough active play on enough active
moves White has good chances to to to
keep them keep the position equal he
went to c7 and that played rook to the
six yeah his ideas rook e8 and Queenie's
have trying to secure the position yeah
okay after group d 6 I could also play
h5 was an interesting alternative look
the eighth look b1 intending would be
seven
and then rooke be a troop d one back
this could be a funny funny way to end
the game with the draw a pretty logical
result it seems the game was once was
even for for a long time yeah if we if
we go back this did not happen I played
rugby 6 as mentioned and he went ruki
eight yeah that's that sets pretty a
pretty logical move he wants to go
Queenie 7 and he covers his six as well
if he is doing something else we can
look at this the check on c 1 i'm king
age too queena form takes takes and Ruby
6 yeah and we just have an equal
position there is a there is nothing
going on after he wanted to fight of
course he wants to try somehow to win
the game he went through yet and I
played Bishop to g4 h4 of course was a
dual-purpose move it wants to get this
attacking unit in the game with h5 h6
tried to mate on g7 but also gives my
oops a bit much here I wanted to
actually just draw this it gives my king
some additional breathing space ok he
played night of eight back ultimately
trying to take the e5 pawn when to age
five and he took yeah he could have
played the Queen e7 as well after that I
can take and go air for and this is
definitely enough for a draw SD a pawn
to a6 porn will drop am super active
here so there is no no way for black too
to account even yet we need this
position yeah we can continue that g5g
305 yeah this is pretty logical oops
line that might have happened and it's
it's just a draw really unless someone
else's blundering and really heavily bit
it is other than that it's just a draw
yeah yeah this was Queenie seven but he
took on age five ticks and ninety-six
really tried to get to the pawn um yeah
here I I didn't have any any time left
really and I made a small error in
calculation I thought I played e6 and I
really thought I'm winning here which
which was a mistake was a mistake and
not the move fortunately but the the
idea that I could I could win here my
idea of course law said and threatening
on f7 I threatened loop d7 all kinds of
things and yeah what is his move yeah he
cannot take on d6 of colleges just wins
wins the house or Queen f7 assess also
on um it's probably even higher even
stronger yeah this wins the Queen I'm
sorry if it's totally enough yeah so he
really it looks like he has no move yet
if he takes here I'm grabbing here yeah
this happened in the game of course but
he has a he has a defense this check I
didn't see that check and this check all
of a sudden I didn't see beforehand that
this square is available and there was a
bit shocked at first that I had
overlooked this but it turned out to be
not not any problem why
is active enough to to keep the game in
balance I went to g3 he took with the
Queen ARELIS really no other move takes
takes and now I just took on a six yeah
it's it's a simple simple line now Luke
a six I'm threatening to take on a seven
he needs to keep both pawns to even have
some hope so King is a rookie seven and
now King Jeff for this is the point my
king is quickly joining the action after
King f7 I go kini five and here black
has zero absolutely zero winning chances
he went to be seven and I just played F
for him and he has no way forward King
on the e-file his answer pierogi sex
with rookie six with check and yeah I'm
just keeping this active position end
and he can do nothing he gave the check
here I went to the fourth-ranked check
again check again and after some checks
we really to a draw there is absolutely
no way forward if you want another way
to draw this like here wyd can also just
just push his pawns if you want if he
wants and get rid of all the pawns it's
also a way to do to get a draw in I mean
and black has no moves really to to to
play on yeah so a draw draw at the end
it seems that the biggest opportunity
that i really had in the game to to go
for something was right in the opening
when after luke t 8 i fail to appreciate
that this this night d5 move was much
stronger than I then had thought and um
this um I think Jeff would have led to
to a situation where he needed to be
super super precise in fact he played
very precisely in the game if you
remember this this sequence here when he
was calculating correctly that 97 was
good this was a good defensive job here
it is really hanging by a thread but
it's exactly like this working for black
um I guess a fair result I mean I looked
at it with the calm bandit never gave
any anything substantial to either side
so I think it draws besides this 95
moment in the opening 95 is assessed by
the computer by almost plus one just to
put it in perspective it's a very very
strong booth yeah unfortunately I didn't
I didn't really ya understand that this
was so strong but the game was
interesting i'm pretty sure if we if we
look at the position like around around
here here this is not easy to play I
mean he really played it played a very
good very good to defense yen discerned
the disposition I think a much weaker
player I could have gotten into trouble
easily here with with some less precise
moves ok I hope you enjoyed this game of
course i also i was glad with the draw I
mean enjoys ok right after this game I
thought I had I had to spoil it a little
bit better to put it in perspective
really the computer finds nothing great
besides this 95 moment ok thanks for
watching